you may think that watching this video
requires very little energy but in
reality your body is buzzing with
activity your eyes and ears are sending
signals to your brain that it processes
so you can see and hear everything on
the screen at the same time you are
creating new memories allowing you to
remember what you are learning but how
does your body do this so quickly you
barely know it's happening the answer is
through the action of billions of cells
called neurons that work together to
form your nervous system
study of how neurons function and
interact so we can see hear smell taste
feel think and move is called
neurobiology
let's start with the basics in 1888 a
neuroscientist named Santiago Ramon
ikahal visualized one of the first
neurons ever seen through a microscope
and documented what he saw in several
famous drawings
these pictures led to the classification
and naming of the three main parts of
the neuron the cell body the dendrites
and the Axon
you can think of the dendrites as the
inbox of the neuron the cell body is the
person reading the email and formulating
a response and the axon as the outbox
the dendrites are branch-like
projections extending from the cell body
through which the neuron gathers
information from its environment
including other cells the cell body
houses the nucleus and many of the
cellular organs known as organelles
which Aid in processing incoming
messages from the dendrites and
regulating the production of outputs
like proteins or other molecules
lastly the axon is a longer less
branched projection from the cell body
from which the neuron sends outgoing
signals to other cells
but how exactly does a signal received
by dendrites travel all the way down
along axons so fast the answer is
electricity neurons are able to generate
electrical signals that can rapidly
travel through the cell sometimes up to
120 meters per second which is over 260
miles per hour these signals are created
by the movement of ions a type of atom
that carries an electrical charge across
the cell membrane this movement changes
the electrical charge on the inside of
the cell versus the outside of the cell
resulting in an electrical signal called
an action potential
when an action potential reaches the end
of an axon it triggers the activation of
electrically sensitive proteins
these proteins then facilitate the
release of neurotransmitters small
molecules that neurons use to
communicate with each other into the
tiny space where two cells meet also
known as a synapse
here the neurotransmitters are detected
by membrane proteins on the receiving
cell which initiates a specific action
the generation or cessation of an action
potential
through this process billions of cells
are able to talk to each other and form
the complex network of interconnected
neurons that make up the nervous system
the cells that make up the brain and
spinal cord are collectively called the
central nervous system or CNS
CNS is responsible for both sending
information from and processing
information sent back to the brain
all of the neurons outside of the
central nervous system make up the
peripheral nervous system
which is responsible for carrying out
commands from the CNS as well as sending
information from the rest of the body
and the environment to the CNS
so next time you watch a video while all
may seem simple and routine from the
outside you now know that a flurry of
complex and well-coordinated activity on
the inside is responsible for all you
see hear understand and remember
including the colors sounds and the
story you've just experienced